quel est le point commun entre Guiraud
et Claudia Schiffer
ils ont fait tous les deux une pub
Citroën sauf que pour Giroud l'airbag
n'est pas sorti
j'accueille Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir
société pêche illégale de thon au large
des côtes françaises Évelyne Thomas est
monté au créneau laissez-moi nager
tranquille
NASA lors des vols spatiaux les
excréments serviront d'énergie
électrique seul bémol si l'équipage est
constipé la navette ralentie
qui est en CP
une info pour Geneviève de Fontenay une
japonaise élue Miss Univers une édition
2007 riche bon quelques déceptions Miss
Liban c'était prise une requête Miss
Darfour trop mince l'écharpe ne tient
pas miss Randa plus de bras impossible
de mettre sa couronne toute seule
Miss Belgique la plus con n'est pas
forcément la plus belle
miss Kaboul très jolie mais entièrement
voilée attention
au piège si vous sortez avec miscabul et
que vous ressentez une douleur au bas
des reins c'est peut-être Mister Kaboul
[Applaudissements]
faits divers en Corrèze arrestation d'un
gérontophile oui un jeune maçon violet
les vieilles dames grosse déception de
Bernadette Chirac qui court attirer
l'attention s'habille en jaune
[Applaudissements]
sport Guiraud entraînera le FC Lens
c'est le transfert de l'année une
tondeuse neuve de survêtement moule les
trois packs de cristallines
Guy Roux pourtant savourait sa retraite
je le cite le matin quand je me lève je
n'ai plus 25 gaillards sur le dos une
phrase attribue à tort à Pascal Sevran
à ce propos quel est le point commun
entre Guiraud et Claudia Schiffer
ils ont fait tous les deux une pub
Citroën sauf que pour Giroud l'airbag
n'est pas sorti
il fallait trouver pas mal
pour battre Laure Manaudou Philippe
Lucas a engagé une nageuse roumaine la
nageuse roumaine tu peux la tabasser la
laisser 24 heures dans l'eau tout le
monde s'en fout tu balances une pièce de
temps en temps
bises 22 costumes de Michael Jackson
19000 dollars pour une veste en revanche
le pantalon n'est pas parti une
braguette avec des boutons en forme de
Mickey ça m'amuse que les enfants
je sais pas où il va chercher ça
dernière minute madame Stallone n'ira
pas en vacances sur la Côte d'Azur oui
je voulais dire la pêche au thon a
repris
suivez un minimum quand même
[Applaudissements]
et on termine par l'adieu à Jean-Claude
brialet une cérémonie très émouvante
corps aurait pu commenter Frédéric
Mitterrand
bonsoir
pour rendre hommage au prince de la
nouvelle vague dans des iconoclast et
Sinik des cinémas français je cite
toutes les conneries que j'ai lu dans
Gala nos plus grandes stars c'était mise
sur leur 31
Marc-Olivier Fogiel habillé pour
l'occasion en croque-mort un costume qui
lui va si bien offrait son bras à Claire
Chazal toujours en deuil de Philippe
Torreton Catherine Deneuve elle arborait
un improbable pu la rayure gagnée
vraisemblablement dans une soirée La
Halle aux vêtements
Dominique bessenard habillé en noir sa
mincit renonça au dernier moment à
prononcer le raisons funèbre son cheveu
sur la langue
déclenchantillarité mais sans doute le
plus bel hommage fut l'arrivée impromptu
d'un tout petit homme haut comme une
écrevisse frère % de Mimie Mathy le
président Sarkozy
gajon que Jean-Claude observateur aigu
de la Comédie humaine aurait goûté
pleinement cette cérémonie bonsoir
merci Stéphane
[Applaudissements]
qui vient de faire là c'est très
difficile parce que au fond au fond
d'ailleurs en vérité tout le monde est
horriblement triste de la mort de
Jean-Claude Brialy bon et en même temps
caricaturé Fredo comme ça sur ce sujet
là ça pouvait très casse-gueule et en
vérité c'était poétique et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu